the legendary singer and actress is
known for her what do we say quick wit
chart-topping hits and award-winning
performances in moonstruck and of course
the Sonny and Cher Comedy Hour Cher's
life story is now being told on Broadway
it's called the Cher show and the lead
role is played by not one but three
different actresses we met with the
ladies of the show and then would share
herself she opened up about the joys and
the challenges of bringing her story to
the stage is it uncomfortable watching
your life on stage only in a few parts
why didn't you agree to it Cher they
couldn't have done it without your
permission I don't know because it's
very personal yeah you didn't know what
I was getting into I didn't know that
when you're telling the person about
your life and you're sitting there and
you're kissing and all that and then all
of a sudden you go there and you see in
real time in real life what you went
through the Cher show takes audiences on
a journey through Cher's iconic career
sparkles and beads more beads that's
what happens when you're doing cher it
took three actors to play the role each
was given a name to represent the
different stages of Cher's life I'm
Stephanie J block and I play star I'm
teal wicks and I play lady and I'm
Mikayla diamond and I play babe her life
does have so many different chapters and
that it does take the three of us but I
look at you Mikayla because you're born
in 1999 did you even know Sharra's music
did you know cher the person I mean what
was she to you
I had one DVD sitting on my home and
that was burlesque and I've watched that
a bajillion million times with my mom
and it was my favorite movie so you were
just graduated from and you were going
where I graduated from LaGuardia High
School I was going to Carnegie Mellon
for musical theater and then a week
before I was about to pack up my entire
apartment and go I got the call that I
had booked it
it's strange I may say cher is a
producer on the show and gave her
feedback even up until opening night
it's no secret that in the beginning she
was not happy with the show and how did
you all deal with that it came down to
okay well we are here together on this
stage in front of all these people no
matter what trying to put on a really
good show and get to the heart of this
woman and I think what made her such a
great actor is that she's tapped into
human authenticity and I feel like we
all had to believe that we are authentic
actors and that eventually she would be
on board with us we should make it very
clear she's very happy with the show she
loves she is very happy with he's very
happy that she told me that she had
worked with each of you individually
yeah so I I'm dying to know what it's
like the notes that she did what was the
best advice she gave what was the advice
that she said well no sure if I want to
do that immediately she wanted to work
on my walk so she she was right to write
this is the thing we share and I've said
it a couple times but I think it's right
she's not a but she's in and she's
feminine and strong
she's yes and no she is this kind of
all-encompassing and I find that she's
not her but she's in Hanuman's she's
kind of so with me she kept saying you
need to be a bit softer and you know I'd
never really thought or viewed her in
that way but that's the way she views
herself one thing she told me when we
had our little kind of one-on-one in my
dressing room was she said I'm people
think I'm so tough and I'm not that
tough and she said it in a way that's
like she's still shocked that people
think that she's this tough chick
michaela what was her note to you she
reminded me that she was always always
painfully shy even as she grew up she
really was just thrust into different
different challenges and she just kept
rising to the occasion so tell me what
this show means to each of you it's
really special as an actor to have such
lovely scenes with other women and so
women who you're all playing each other
so it's it's very therapeutic it's our
Shara P call it therapy Sheriff
for you Stephanie for me I think it has
gifted me a sort of freedom and
acceptance
so I speak up more I believe in myself
more and that's all because I'm playing
shares so I'm a different Stephanie
because I was gifted this role I know
all the ladies are great and can you
imagine you're on the share on the show
singing with cher on stage but this is
how particular now cher is such a
perfectionist
she says this about herself on opening
night guys they had a rehearsal at 3
o'clock in the afternoon because she had
changes and she wanted to see it before
it went on there 3 o'clock in the
afternoon love that I mean I love how
she says I was gifted this role yes it's
a gift to be able to play cher they all
found that in a special responsibility
responsibility and think of Michaela
who's just graduating from high school
and then she gets that that's pretty
good yeah well she was near playings in
the audience that's tricky will she go
back to school if you go back to college
I didn't ask her that I'm thinking she's
off to a good start
yeah what she wants now that's a good
question may the cher show by the way is
playing now at the Neil Simon theatre
right here in New York City for those of
you would like to see it's worth going
to see well I think they have therapy
and we have gala P
[Laughter]